Using only candlesticks and price
action, I have built a trading strategy
where I can consistently make over $250
per day on average only trading 60 to 90
minutes in the morning [music]
before going to a full-time job. And
after over 9 years of day trading, I've
realized something. [music]
Most traders are completely
overcomplicating things. They load their
charts up with indicators like RSI,
MACD, moving averages, volume profiles,
trying to find some magic signal that
tells [music] them when to buy and when
to sell. But the reality is the
candlesticks themselves tell you
everything [music] you need to know. And
over the years, I've uncovered specific
price action patterns that are
incredibly accurate at signaling where
the market is likely to move next. And
these aren't the basic candlestick
patterns you'll see in every other
YouTube video. These are advanced
patterns that have been extremely
profitable for me over the years. So in
this video, I'm going to break down
exactly what these patterns look like
and what they tell you about the market
and how I use them every single morning
while live streaming my trades in front
of thousands of people here on YouTube.
And with each of these patterns, I want
to walk through you through the theory
of how they work, real chart examples,
and then how to actually use them to
trade. So you can have a practical
takeaway from each pattern to be able to
use it yourself. And at the end, I'm
going to walk you through a real trade
example that combines a lot of these.
Because any pattern in trading, you do
not want to be using it solely by
yourself. You want to combine things to
help improve your accuracy. And so the
first one of these is called a failed
breakout. You have the market and
anything you're looking at where the
market comes up, does something like a
double top, you know, that looks like a
pretty clean resistance zone. Well, the
market will sometimes retest that and
actually break out. And so, a lot of
traders will think, when they first
start out, "Oh, well, it's breaking out.
It's going to continue this trend
higher, and so I should actually buy."
And in reality, over time, I've realized
this is a perfect spot where a lot of
the times the market will actually fail,
and it's baiting people back in to
thinking that it's going to go higher,
but it will actually reverse and start a
major trend shift. And so, this is a
huge indicator of potentially a
reversal. And so, that's the theory of
how it works. An example here, as you
can see, here is a market looking at a
1-minute chart. It's kind of had a move
up, a sell-off, and then you can see
right here, if I draw a zone based on
these previous highs, barely made a new
high here, barely had a breakout
attempt, and then completely reversed.
And to me, that shows a failed breakout.
And so, this is a bigger picture example
of what this can look like. Now, a
smaller example is actually if we look
at right here and zoom into this, is if
we kind of go back in the chart here, is
you can see right here the market sells
off, kind of starts to go sideways, and
then it has this big candlestick here.
And so, you would think, you know, a lot
of times people would see this as a bear
flag, which is a continuation pattern.
Essentially, the market comes down,
consolidates, gets a little bit of that
strength back, and then it's going to
continue and make another leg lower. But
instead, what happens here, is you can
see this candlestick, huge big bearish
candlestick here, that moves lower, and
then immediately afterwards, it starts
to reverse and flip higher. Especially
with this candlestick as well, combined,
this becomes a failed breakout to the
downside. This is now how you can use it
as well on a smaller micro pattern. You
initially have up here where it's a
bigger picture fail breakout, but this
is how you can also use it on the
smaller time frames. And we'll learn a
lot more about this in my trade example
in a few minutes here, but a great way
is if you were thinking and looking to
buy here, this would signal the low for
you. I use this all the time in my
trades. This is probably the number one
pattern that I use is seeing that this
reverses here and it's a fail breakout.
So, I'm going to think, "Okay, well,
it's going to fake here. Buyers will
come in and push this higher." Now, to
dive into this a tiny bit more, what I
would call the next pattern is a bait
[music]
candlestick. The theory of what this is
like is the market's moving down here
and all of a sudden it starts to
accelerate an extreme amount. And I'm
talking, you know, the candlesticks
before that have kind of looked like
this and then all of a sudden you have a
huge candlestick to the downside. And
old me would have thought that, "Okay,
well, this is the market's really going
to get going here." And sometimes it
does happen, but the signal here is if
this candlestick reverses, [music]
if a massive uh pretty much right after
or a couple candlesticks, the price
fully covers the can- recovers the
candlestick and breaks the high. To me,
that is a signal that this has faked
lower. Essentially, what happens here is
you were in an a healthy trend of the
downside and then it gets overextended
here. The market gets so extreme that it
has to snap back. I call this an
unhealthy move. And on a smaller time
frame, if you see this, this is again a
very huge bottoming signal. And we'll
look at an example here in a second, but
once you see this and it recovers, that
is a great signal for it to continue
higher. And I'll talk about how to use
that in a trade in a second. Let me show
you a real example of this just last
week where the market had a big move up
here and then had what, you know, what I
just called that little failed breakout
to the upside and then it started to
reverse lower. And so it started to
really get going here and then all of a
sudden it had this massive bearish
candlestick here. And when I watched
this in real time, to me that was a huge
candlestick that signaled, "Okay, you
know, on the on the one side, well, it
could just continue lower cuz this is a
big trend shift and reversal, but the
question is that I want in your mind is
well, what happens if it does reverse
this candlestick?" That to me starts to
signal like this because when the
market's very volatile, it'll have these
bait and switches. And so the next
candlestick immediately reversed it
here, which is a massive reversal
candlestick. And you can see the market
actually ended up coming back and
testing this area, but it never made a
new low. And so how I like to use these
and those failed breakouts for trades,
and I'll show you a real full example
here in a second, but if I'm thinking
that this is going to reverse to upside
now, this is the low I want to put my
stop. This bottom is not going to get
broken if the market is going to trend
and continue higher. Now, if this just
bottoms here and continues lower, you
know, the signal didn't work out. That's
fine. Move on, right? Trading, you're
not going to win every trade. But the
idea here is if this reverses up, this
is where you I want my stop to be at
because it's a really clean spot and
it's behind this extreme bottom that the
market's put in using that pattern. Now,
another extremely powerful reversal
pattern that almost seems so basic, I
use it in every single trade. So I would
highly recommend paying attention to
this even if you feel like you know it
because there's little nuances that
really are important to pay attention to
with using a head and shoulders pattern.
This pattern is probably my most
powerful pattern and my bread and butter
for my trade setups. And so, the basic
idea is if you have a downtrend, it's
made by lower lows and lower highs. And
an uptrend is signaled by higher highs
and higher lows. And a head and
shoulders is the turning point of that
where those lower lows and lower highs
start to reverse and start to make that
new uptrend. And so, I use this to help
signal where that is and a bottom in the
market. And some really keys about it is
that well, one, this could be a failed
breakout. You can combine a failed
breakout, what we were talking about
earlier, with the kind of bait
candlestick. If the bottom of your head
and shoulders down here is signaled with
a bait candlestick, it's extremely,
extremely powerful. I've got a whole
candlestick pattern sheet here that
walks you through other patterns that
I'm not going to go over in this video,
but I highly recommend checking it out.
You can check it out via this QR code or
I'll leave a link for it in the
description below. And so, check out
this chart example right here where the
market right here opens up, starts to
sell off, and when you're looking at
candlesticks and reading them, just
don't read into the micro moves of each
candlestick. A lot of people like to
look at all the, you know, the dojis,
the hammer candlesticks, all this stuff,
and that over complicates things as well
with adding more indicators. You can
over complicate just reading
candlesticks. All I look at is, okay,
what is the price doing? We have a big
move, a little pullback, another move, a
pullback. And so, to me, I'm looking at
the swings. Okay, we made a lower low, a
lower low, a lower high, a lower high.
Now, we've all of a sudden got
accelerated a little bit here. So, we
made a big extreme low, but to me,
looking at that is, well, we kind of
have a little bait candlestick here, a
little reversal. And then, if you
actually look over here, well, this was
a pre-market low. So, if I just draw a
little reversal zone here, well, this
could actually turn into a failed
breakout. And then, also just looking at
the head and shoulders part, here's kind
of the left shoulder, where it makes a
lower low here. And then, we have an
extreme low put in with a failed
breakout, which is a great combo for
these. And then, you have the market
push up, and then it pulls back. And so,
to form the head and shoulders, I would
assume that this would I would want to
see it pop up like this to confirm the
head and shoulders being formed. And why
this is important here, and why you
don't just look for this and then buy
and bet to the upside, is because it's
not formed yet. This is the hard part
about predicting reversals, is well, the
market could do this. It could pull back
and then just continue lower. And
there's a no head and shoulders formed
there. There's no switch in, you know,
the lower lows turning into a lower high
and then a higher high and a higher low.
And then, you know, you capture a move
up. That's why you have to be patient,
you know, even though there's a lot of
signals here showing that a reversal
could happen, you have to wait for this
right side of the shoulder to form, pull
back, and then start to reverse higher,
and then you can jump in on a trade
right here. And then, you know, it kind
of plays out. It pulls back a little
bit, gets a little choppy, but in in the
end, it has a clean move to the upside
that was signaled from this reversal.
And this is a trade I actually jumped
into and we'll look at here in a second.
And so, how I use head and shoulders is
they are a very good final confirmation
that a bottom is getting put in and I
use them a lot of the times as my final
entry signal. Now, head and shoulders
are more of a conservative reversal
pattern. Sometimes the market, now this
is the hard part about reversal trading,
is that the market is in more of a
conservative mode where the bottoms are
a little slower. And there's other times
where if I kind of talk through the
theory here, is where the market will
have a move up and then it will make a
double top before selling off. It won't
necessarily need to make something like
a head and shoulders before selling off.
It'll happen faster where it makes a
head a double top here or sometimes what
I just call a lower high where it
doesn't even really test the extreme and
make a double top. And that's the thing
a lot of people get mixed up on is you
don't need for a double top to happen.
It does not need to perfectly touch the
same price. If it just does some kind of
double test like this, even if it makes
a new high, to me that's still a double
top. And so to show you a real example
here, we have an uptrend and the market
makes a high here and then a lower high.
And so this signals essentially to me a
double top in the market. And if there's
other factors that I'm seeing where the
market could start to top here, well
that is a great signal to trade off of.
And again, you don't want to be blindly
using these by themselves all the time
because a lot of times there could be a
double top right here and it looks like
it's going to sell off, but the bigger
picture trend takes off. And so that's
why you want to combine this stuff with
something like a resistance zone or
where you see kind of another pattern or
a bigger picture trend or another
pattern here. If we go into the next one
is an uptrend line. If you have an
uptrend line that the market's fitting
and then all of a sudden, and if you
actually draw this on the top side of
things too, is all of a sudden it's it's
respecting the lows, it's respecting the
highs, and then all of a sudden it makes
a a high here that doesn't make it back
up to the trend line, and it comes down
and starts to test this. To me, that's a
much more of a a signal that this could
break and sell off. And so, using trend
lines as well is extremely important.
And another thing about trend lines is
actually, if we talk about theory here
for a second, is if you have a trend
line or a channel that the market's in
and it's ping-ponging like this and it
actually breaks to the upside of the
channel, to just to extend this real
quick, it'll often that signals that the
trend is over as well. A lot of the
times I would think, "Oh, well, this is
going to get going. It's going to You
know, the trend's going to go even
higher and faster now." But a lot of
times that's it getting overextended and
unhealthy, and it'll actually pull back.
It might make something like a double
top. And so, this is where you can
combine these things again, right? Is
you have a a break to the upside where
it's overextended of this upwards
channel, and then if the market puts in
a double top, well, likely very often
this starts a downtrend and the trend is
going to shift. And so, this is a
recording from my live stream. I
literally live stream my trades on
YouTube
>> [music]
>> every day starting at 9:00 a.m. Eastern.
I highly recommend checking it out.
Seeing this stuff in real time is
completely different than talking about
it in hindsight and in theory. And
executing it it is a very hard part
about the reality of trading. And so,
[music]
on this day though, if we can combine
what we're kind of talking about here in
looking for these patterns that the
market has is the basics of what I do
with my trading. And you can see I have
a reversal trade checklist here. But all
I'm looking at here is this the swings,
the lower lows and lower highs, and if a
head and shoulders sets up here.
>> [music]
>> And so, as I'm seeing this develop, I am
seeing that this makes a spike lower. We
talked about earlier how it did a little
fail breakout essentially of this
reversal zone. And then from there,
okay, is this going to pull back and
make a head and shoulders? And if
[music] that does happen, how do I want
to execute on a trade to capture the
swing back to the upside because this
right here is most likely going to be
[music] the bottom. And so I look for
these every single day I actually trade.
And so to zoom through this a little
bit, is the market reversed here, set up
our head and shoulders, and then I
entered in on a trade as it broke the
swing high of that head and shoulders to
me cuz to me that's a confirmation that
the head and shoulders has happened and
it's now likely to push higher from
there and I can capture a larger swing
in the market. And so from there, you
know, I put my stop below the extreme
low down here cuz to me the bottom of
that head and shoulders is where the
market will likely reverse. And then
from there, all it is is looking at what
the potential is for the market to do.
Could it do a huge move up? Could it
just do a volatile back and forth? And
I'm not going to go too much into
managing, but that's how I essentially
use these entries to help signal when a
trade is going to happen. And you can
see here it took a while for this to get
going. That's what I'm talking about
here where the market recently has kind
of been slow to bottom where you got to
be patient and let kind of things play
out. And then from there, after a while,
it starts to accelerate up and I can
capture a big swing on the day. And this
is something I do every single morning.
I start the market opens at 9:30 and
I'm, you know, this trade is kind of
done by 10:30. And so that's an hour
worth of the market being open that I'll
be trading. But I do start live
streaming if you want to come look at
check it out [music] 30 minutes before.
And so go and get that cheat sheet that
I talked about in the description below
this video. It'll walk you through a lot
of other candlestick patterns that are
really important that I didn't go over
in this video. And if you want to learn
more about my strategy, check out this
video right here. It'll talk you through
my checklist for my trades. And of
course, if you want to dive even more,
come check out my live streams on
YouTube. They're completely free to
join.